It's been very strange for you
doing press recently,
because of "Star Wars,"
obviously.
You don't want to talk to people
too much about it.
They don't want you to ruin it.
I know you're going to do
another season of
"Big Little Lies."
You really probably can't talk
about that that much.
"Twin Peaks" you haven't --
Has that been strange to do
press for projects
that are so under wraps?
-I'm the most boring interview,
I think, possible.
-That's not true.
-Thank you for having me here,
because I can't say a thing.
[ Laughter ]
I mean, literally, I can't wait
for everyone to see "Star Wars,"
because all I can say is,
yes, I can confirm
I have purple hair in the film.
-Oh, there you go.
That's nice of you to confirm
that much for us.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-And it's a great color.
I recommend it.
-Did they let you give them
feedback on the color of purple?
-Yes.
-Oh, they did?
That's nice.
-Yeah.
-See? You have a successful
enough career,
and they let you
choose your purple.
-Isn't that beautiful? Yeah.
-That's well-deserved.
Is your family
excited about "Star Wars"?
Either generation?
-They are. Everybody.
-Yeah.
-I mean, my kids --
I'm thrilled that my kids
are actually going to get
to see me in something.
I can talk about the film.
Not that you don't start kids on
David Lynch at like age 5.
But I haven't.
-Your kids are like,
"I have a lot of questions about
'Wild at Heart.'"
-Yeah, exactly.
But my parents took me to see
"Star Wars"
when I was 7 years old.
It's --
-Yeah.
-I mean, we're all obsessed,
aren't we?
It is a cultural phenomenon.
-And this is a photo --
I am assuming this is
from the premiere.
Is that accurate?
-Yes. From our press in London.
-And this must be exciting,
as well.
One of the things about these
new "Star Wars" movies
is there's so many
strong female characters.
Is that really exciting
to be a part of this generation
of "Star Wars"?
-It really is incredible.
And let's say, as a deep homage,
we had the greatest muse
possible in Princess Leia,
our beloved Carrie Fisher, so...
[ Applause ]
Yes.
So to continue that tradition
and have "Star Wars"
and the incredible producers
working on the film
and Ryan Johnson
who wrote and directed it,
have these incredible female,
complicated, powerful women
is really exciting.
-You mentioned "Jurassic Park."
Is that a film -- You say a lot
of people ask you about it.
Is that a film your children
have found,
and are they
impressed with that?
-Uh, I think so.
Well, my daughter
actually just saw it
for the first time at Halloween.
-Oh, wow.
-Her friends wanted to see it.
And for years, she was like,
"Are you kidding?
I do not want to see my mother
being chased by a raptor.
That is not interesting to me."
[ Laughter ]
-You mean -- does she in general
play the cool card of
"I'm not interested in
seeing mom in movies"?
-She's really interested
in movies.
But me in jeopardy wasn't
deeply interesting to her.
-Okay.
Oh, that's very sweet of her
that she didn't want to see you
get chased by dinosaurs.
-But my son seemed fine with it.
[ Laughter ]
"Get her! Get her!"
-He's like, "I feel like
one of the dinosaurs
would have caught you, Mom."
[ Laughter ]
-Yeah, exactly.
"I've seen you run, girl."
[ Laughter ]
-But when she saw it,
was she happy?
Did she think it was cool?
-She thought it was cool.
She loved it.
And now they have both seen
"Star Wars" a few days ago,
and I think they were really
excited by that too, so...
-I think "Jurassic Park" --
and I know there is another one
of those coming as well,
which I'm sure you can't tell me
a word about,
so I won't even ask.
-Can't tell you a word.
-Yeah.
But I will say, it still strikes
me that that moment of
seeing dinosaurs for the first
time in "Jurassic Park,"
like, what movies were
before that moment
and what movies were
after that moment
is one of those huge gaps that
in the theater, you realize --
I still remember that awe.
-Well, it's incredible that
when we were making it,
people now have said,
"Wow, being part of
a blockbuster,
what did that feel like?"
But it felt like any other kind
of incredible, independent film,
in that it was a pioneered film,
because CGI hadn't
really happened.
-Right.
-So Steven Spielberg was there
inventing with
these brilliant men,
like ILM and Sam Winston,
who did the animatronics,
like how to create
these creatures.
And it was awe-inspiring.
-Yeah.
And you were then
one of the first people
who had to as an actor
go like this...
-Yes.
-To something
that was not there.
-Exactly. Yes.
[ Laughter ]
The mouth-agape shot
from "Jurassic Park"
has been seen a lot.
People are like,
"Oh, my God, I love you.
You're the one that goes..."
[ Laughter ]
-And it was probably just a guy
with, like, a tennis ball
and a stick.
-Yes, it was an X
on a tennis ball. Exactly right.
Also scary.
-Yes, exactly.
But I think, again,
that is a credit to your
incredible talents as an actor.
-Very sweet.
-I am always so happy
to have you here.
Congratulations on the movie.
I can't wait to see you
at the Golden Globes.
Best of luck.
-Me too! Me too.
-Thank you.
Laura Dern, everybody.